The distance between the points is 5 times the square root of 5. Great solving
if you found that one. This is a rough sketch of the points on the coordinate
plane. Notice that I'm not precise, and that's okay. We're really just after
the difference in the x values, and the difference in the y values, or the
change in them. So, to find the distance between these two points, we need to
set up our right triangle. First we'll find the horizontal distance. We'll go
from x equals 2 to x equals negative 3. That's a distance of five units. Now if
that's confusing, try thinking about it by starting at x equals negative 3. If
we start at x equals negative 3 and count up to x equals 2, we will travel the
five units horizontally. We want to think about the horizontal distance when
traveling on a number line. Now we need to find the vertical distance. We start
at y equals negative 4 which is here. And then we climb all the way up to y
equals 6 here. The vertical distance between y equals negative 4 and y equals 6
is ten units. So we know this vertical distance is simply ten. Now that we have
the legs of our right triangle, we can solve for the distance. We'll have the
change in x squared which is 5 squared. the change in y squared, which is 10
squared equal to d squared, our hypotenus. We'll add the sum of the squares, to
get d squared equals 125, and then, we'll square root both sides, to get 1d is
equal to the square root of 25 times 5. We simplify this square root to get our
final answer of 5 root 5. Again great work if you got some of that correct.
Even more amazing if you got it right on your first try.